[Music]
the playstation 4 pro represents a new
move for Sony while the company has
refreshed many of its consoles before
the ps4 Pro marks the first time a mid
generational design has received a
significant boost in processing power is
it worth it let's find out one of the
first things you'll notice about the ps4
pro is that it's 11.6 by 2.1 by 12 inch
chassis is big at 7.2 pounds it's also
quite heavy in terms of aesthetics it
maintains the ps4 s a slanted design but
ops to use the ps4 Slim's more rounded
corners as opposed to the originals
sharper edges the console has a new
power LED light bar on the front which
starts on the left and trails off to the
right coupled with the light bar or
physical power and eject buttons the pro
sort of looks like a ps4 slim stacked on
top of the original ps4 and as two slits
that go around the chassis
despite being a 4k capable system the
pro doesn't support 4k blu-ray discs
this is an odd and unfortunate omission
which slightly detracts from the package
in terms of ports the pro brings back
the optical spit off' which was removed
from the ps4 slim in addition to the two
USB 3.1 ports on the front the pro
offers a third USB 3.1 port on the back
like the original ps4 and ps4 slim
before it the pro model has an
integrated power supply which saves you
the trouble of figuring out where to
position a bulky external power brick
inside the chassis the faster graphics
processing unit is arguably the most
significant boost the ps4 pro offers the
GPU is based on AIM these new Polaris
micro architecture which the graphics
card manufacturer debuted with its
Radeon R X 480 GPU it's 911 megahertz
frequency is 14% higher than the
original models equivalent
it also offers twice the number of
compute units with 36c use and features
4.2 teraflops of performance which is to
point to a times as much as the original
ps4 the console itself still offers
eight gigabytes of gddr5 memory which it
shares with the CPU but sony has added
one gigabyte of traditional dram of the
CP
this allows the x86-based processor to
run the operating system and streaming
video applications at 4k this extra dram
also frees up some of the faster gddr5
memory for the GPU the CPU is still an 8
core Jaguar AMD processor but its
frequency has been raised from 1.6
gigahertz to 2.1 gigahertz which amounts
to a 31% boost the ps4 pro also comes
with a larger 1 terabyte hard drive the
main reason to get excited about the ps4
pro is the prospect of better graphics
the new console is completely backwards
compatible with the existing ps4 library
and some games will receive graphical
enhancements on the pro some titles may
use the extra processing power to
bolster frame rates while others may
render at a higher resolution some games
may run natively at 4k but sony says the
majority of games will use a 4k
upscaling technique a company called a
checkerboard rendering which is
essentially a 4k rendering shortcut that
isn't as taxing on hardware it's not
quite as sharp as native 4k but it does
look surprisingly close ps4 games will
not receive Pro enhancements out of the
box however developers will have to
patch their games to take advantage of
the pros extra processing power
developers can actually use the added
power as they see fit instead of
cranking up the resolution developers
may choose to increase graphical
fidelity or offer improved frame rates
or use better anti-aliasing this means
the pro could bolster visuals at 1080p
to analyze the visual enhancements that
the ps4 Pro offers I compared it against
a regular ps4 I hooked up both
Playstations to different HDMI inputs on
the same TV a 55 inch 4k HDR display I
gather two copies of every ps4 Pro
enhanced games that I could get copies
of and quickly switched between the two
inputs to conduct visual a be tests
because the ps4 Pro can also bolster
1080p graphics I also connected both
systems to a 55 inch 1080p TV and
similarly analyze the visual differences
there for my full analysis I suggest you
read my in-depth written review but the
big takeaway here is that the ps4 Pro
offers a better anti-aliasing that
mitigates unwanted jaggies this is
especially true on the 4k TV this makes
the overall image look sharper and
cleaner for instance in the remastered
version of modern warfare it's easier to
make out the individual hair follicles
on an NP
is beer these aren't mind-blowing
editions by any means but they are
appreciated anti-aliasing effects do
carryover ever-so-slightly at 1080p -
but they're much less noticeable
speaking of 1080p shadow of mordor
offers a super sampling anti-aliasing
with the pro which can make a regular
old HD display look a little sharper
than it actually is some HDR enabled
games like The Last of Us an infamous
second son provide more vibrant and
realistic colors looking up at the sky
in the pro version of second son
I noticed pink streets of light fill out
the clouds this effect wasn't as
prominent on the slim where everything
looked a little more video gaming black
levels also look really black in the
game - a little too black in fact with
textures getting smothered in ultra dark
shadows the PlayStation 4 pro can indeed
make games look better that is if their
patch to take advantage of the extra
processing power but should you buy a
ps4 Pro if you have a 4k HDR TV and are
looking to buy a console I definitely
recommend the pro even if you have a
1080p TV and are looking to buy a
Playstation
I'd still lean towards Sony's newest
console yes it does cost hundred dollars
more than the slim model but you get
more ports twice the storage more
future-proof hardware and some games can
look slightly better at 1080p if you
already have a ps4 however I wouldn't
make the upgrade unless you have a 4k
HDR TV and the extra cash lying around
graphics enthusiasts may appreciate the
improved anti-aliasing and more vibrant
colors but the difference is likely
won't blow you away regardless the ps4
Pro is priced fairly offers a plethora
of features and as the most powerful
console you can buy today for more on
the ps4 Pro check out GameSpot calm &
subscribe to our youtube channel
by
[Music]